and I haven't seen effects this
impressive since Birdemic wow this
assassin sets up I'm wondering why
haven't they already shot this guy if
they knew this dude was bringing Cindy
home with him why didn't they take the
easy shot while he was sleeping on the
lawn chair also holy Johnny Knoxville's
still alive he was killed in that
jackass stunts where they put him in a
porta potty with an irritated Jaguar and
then dropped it in the middle of the
ocean seriously this is the least
salacious part of the movie I could send
this for the stupid over-the-top
character introduction but I think I'm
gonna tap into my ultra liberal side and
say that this character introduction
with the name spelled out in leopard
skin accompanied by individual frames of
tits and ass gives me a socially
conscious boner look I don't know how
long it takes for boner pills to kick in
but they're not like instantaneous right
I mean if this was going down Michael
should have popped that as soon as he
saw Cindy get another pool it's nice to
assassins take so long to kill this one
dude who is currently easily killable
that they make their seductress get all
the way to the BJ stage before taking
him out they could have killed this dude
five minutes ago but I guess the
assassins lust for porn outweighs their
appointed tasks also blowy shadowing
moving on
but why Facundo and Cindy clearly had
him licked I know he used to be a
dangerous assassin but this is a one
two-man job tops sure you have a gun
pointed at Johnny Knoxville but why not
pick up a weight and throw it at him I'm
sure that's a better choice I remember
Lee Harvey Oswald killing JFK with a
wide array of barbells the only reason
why you didn't see it in the Zapruder
film is because they don't want you see
it man this rookie loves big balloon
adventure remake is way darker than the
original also at this point they're
singing along - see you in September
look if the movie really wanted to be
subversive they'd have used the Taylor
Swift version damn it movie I thought
you were going for something really
different with these hanging chads at
the end of your text titles well you're
gonna force me to make it in case you
confused - for seattle botswana joke or
shame again with this book how many of
these goddamn middle aged or revenge
flicks do we have to sit through over
the next decade Mads Denso Liam's Bruce
Charlie's
Keanu it's never gonna stop is it Andy
pres doctor gives the exam that this
movie is currently giving to its viewers
most dangerous time for men is here they
retire they take up some crazy sport
they ditched away from girls younger
than
Donner's but only in a hyper realized
male wish-fulfillment fantasy like this
movie those dickheads living in the real
world will be playing golf the 4 a.m.
napping for hours afterwards and and
then jerking off to Brazilian fart porn
for the rest of the day until they fall
asleep during the tucker carlson show
what about cigarettes I quit good for
you character says he quit something and
is immediately shown doing that very
damn thing in the next scene cliche
let's go of everybody at 50 you know
that can't be a hitman with Alzheimer's
man this is some condescending ass
exposition Cantus exposition wants you a
black kaiser I almost want to do a roll
credits here since this should be the
title of the movie why the hell is it
called polar anyway I think the webcomic
is set in the tundra or some the coldest
we get here is Montana and that's cold
but it ain't that goddamn poles fine
Jesus attractive oh my Jesus is a
handsome man isn't he this conversation
has gone on for all of the sometimes but
it's not really character development or
comedic or informative it's just weirdly
here this is the mike yanagita scene of
this movie what is the deal with
assassin movies and dogs you know then
they're gonna die so why I got involved
though this dog's destiny is as clear as
old yellers lamp lamp lamp lamp enormous
fire isn't this asshole supposed to be
incognito
Jerry doesn't think anyone's after him
but why would he need this many sources
of light for himself
rusty this dog can he played for laughs
but given that Duncan's had this
recurring dream for a long time how has
this never happened before when he's
been startled wait how long his kamil
been living out here it's a good amount
of snow already so she would have had
some experience chopping wood but it's
cool we just need to show how this woman
needs the help of a big strong man to
survive what she's already been
surviving long before he got there if
they're so secure why are they showing
up in a huge display for everyone to see
this message methodology makes as much
sense as Michelle Williams law firm in
venom speak I got your message which one
Jesus this characters dramatic removal
of unnecessary sunglasses bothers the
shit out of me we've already lived
through all those fucking David Caruso
memes man give it a rest just talking to
the black Kaiser makes you nervous
that's racist
why do I get the sense that every page
of this movie screenplay has this hand
cream landed all over if he accepts the
assignment he'll expect 1 million
dollars in his account before he makes a
move
what kind of we need to see the
backstabbing but this is a conversation
they would have had a lot earlier right
in case this perfectly good image of
your target isn't enough here's another
picture from a slightly different angle
that isn't as good why because we have
to make it look like this laptop is
doing something man I know I've bagged
on Hannibal for having a lot of
unnecessary lamps but this is next-level
if our agents were to die in the field
of duty or an unspecified accident
clause in their contract states the
damages would be the beneficiary how
strict is the language in this clause
because johnny Knoxville did not die in
the field of duty and he did not die by
accident
also Damocles is killing us asin's and
denying their pensions to inflate the
value of their company but how many
goddamn assassins just happened to be
turning 50 around the time of their
company's sale also also this is where I
feel like all the hired guns would
figure this out pretty quickly people
making it to retirement dying and simply
looking at the clause in the contract
that states the democlass as the sole
beneficiary there's only so many people
you can kill before someone realizes
who's behind it kids also there are so
many things wrong with the scene if
you're gonna bump uglies with a kid in
the next room you don't shut the door
even if you're a prostitute and why is
the train waking homeboy up when he
lives next to a train I've lived by a
train you get desensitized to that quick
trust me wait is he getting visual
confirmation of his wilting boner here
Duncan looks around the room and finds
his case file on the table getting the
confirmation that he was in fact the
target but did Pedro and his buddies
really ran out this hotel room with
hookers and blow expecting Duncan to
stop by and even if they didn't expect
him to come by now who reads the targets
file when there are hookers and blow to
be had this is kind of a fun scene but
there are also a lot of rooms on this
floor and no one comes out of the room
to see what's happening I don't care how
awesome Duncan is the fact that he and
his surrogate family walk right the hell
out of the front door of this hotel is
less believable than that Ocean's eleven
heist working also what was the point of
him bringing them here he already had
the cash to pay them all and even though
he's a badass he totally put them in
harm's way by having them in the hotel
and don't tell me they had to be in the
room to make the distress call anyone
coulda done that you tried to kill the
black Keyser
with some low-rent Mack
again clowns racism aside yeah what's up
with that you know this is your best
agent so why not send your best squad to
do the job you're gonna have to paint
everything else I don't have to do until
his birthday hubris sure I know it's
within bluets character but it's totally
unnecessary in this situation and is a
literal sense
weird I was the only one that used this
euphemism back when I was in that
pegging face unnecessary title card
notwithstanding the color paladin in
this movie is eye gouging seen more
subtler hues in a kpop music video do
you want a drink before we get started
no no drink Thanks I'm really just here
regarding the questionnaires Wow
thankfully for all of our consciences
the guy that lives in Duncan's Miami
condo just happens to not only be a
sleaze ball but was actively waiting for
someone to show up to do some gross sex
also Duncan's a killer but he seems
otherwise it's like a decent guy see the
kind of dude that would sublet his to
someone that's this obviously demented
isn't doing background checks like 40%
of his job went air coffee yes I know
it's cold up there but there must be a
ton of people up in Montana walking and
driving around faced this is actually a
pretty funny callback but hopefully
Duncan doesn't have any recurring water
dreams or at least motherfuckers are
toast
also how well-stocked is the bookstore
and Radiator Springs Montana I
understand maybe them having a dog care
book but if the fish book that's about
domestic fish in Montana shouldn't any
fish related book sold there be a river
runs through okay make a mess because
this ice well the filmmakers ask
themselves what's absolutely necessary
in the scene and then anything not on a
list went into the movie Austria
Australia oh sure when Duncan tries to
impress Vanessa Hudgins with all the
countries he knows in alphabetical order
she sits there with interest but when I
do it while she's on stage playing me me
and rent at the Hollywood Bowl I get
thrown out of California if you ever
wonder why you keep running into mixed
reviews for this movie it's because it's
the type of movie where one of the goons
is singing a country song outside while
his buddies strangle an overweight
person while Cindy yells USA USA well
one of the guys is on the phone
explaining to the boss that they haven't
found Duncan yet
offsetting all the quiet scenes with
Duncan and Camille the movie decided to
come live with the contrast and the
movie is wrong her boyfriend is not
going to be happy if she doesn't find
the black guy sir I mean does the scene
even need to exist did Vivian think she
needed to tell the assassins that the
boss would be unhappy if they didn't
find Duncan these assassins shoot the
heavy person for
good 12 seconds now is this supposed to
be funny tragic if your answer is
excessive good job ignoring the two
provided choices and scribbling in the
correct answer the Kool Kreem is that
serial weapon slice and towel and here I
thought the guy who did those magic
tricks during the assembly in my Middle
School's awkward even if this movie were
somehow a satire about violence and
through in this scene as a statement on
how kids learn to normalize violence at
an early age it would be embracing the
message it was railing against oh come
on cinemasins I know you took your
brains out long ago but try not to think
about this too hard it's fun kids
haphazardly brandishing knives as fun
and hilarious and fun wait a minute
isn't Duncan in Montana who in Montana
spells neighbor this way unless the
Canadians have infiltrated our American
schools with this extra you nonsense and
then have you ever seen a dead body
that's been in the Sun for three weeks
no but I have watched it over long scene
of hit man teaching inappropriate things
to young kids that seemed like it lasted
for three weeks oh this is the most
curious part of the movie by far Camille
actually encouraged Duncan to teach kids
about his experiences even though we're
going to get a reveal at the end of this
movie that explains that her parents
were murdered by Duncan and that she's
been waiting to get revenge all this
time so what's the purpose of this and
her grand scheme charity is not what's
important it's the bank account me
the Montana Union credit bank and yeah
that's exactly what it says on the wire
transfer I know you're trying to give
Cindy something to do rather than scream
and give unnecessary BJ's but this isn't
all that helpful I've never heard about
Wendy Crawford before I use bourbon mr.
G's just come clean and make this to
come to Montana glamour add already a
human listen tell him how that day never
left my thoughts this is a great
performance by Vanessa Hudgens and this
scene is so good that it really doesn't
belong in the movie I really want to
take us in off but like I said it really
doesn't belong in a movie like this so
here we go littering how the hell do you
know that I'm sure this place in Three
Oaks Montana has very few roads but if
you knew where this lived you wouldn't
even need to stake out the town looking
for I realized that seduction takes a
long time but the assassins were ready
to kill Duncan hours ago and I'm still
unclear on why Cindy has to seduce and
actually be King Duncan before they can
move in to kill him you're trying to say
there isn't one moment where they could
have shot him during this entire time he
was making food for and this entire
thing seems to be different from what
you did at the other three properties
Duncan Oh
either Duncan knew this both coming at
this exact moment or Cindy just gave the
dumbest distraction blowjob in the
history of aural diversionary tactics
it's like Mads Mikkelsen said you
remember Vigo and Eastern Promises when
he fought those guys and the bathhouse
completely naked yeah I want to do that
but I want to do it in fridge and ass
Montana
even if we're faking the fruited Asness
I want to one-up that ergo and get
mother why would this amazing hit man
give away the Facundo is dead and that
he's in the sniper nest right now wait
this asshole had a heat signature option
all the hell was he doing shooting blind
when Duncan was under the bed Jesus is
this seriously the a-team one of them
got and the rest of them just got this
is how the movie could have been awesome
by doing stuff like this throughout now
it's in removal worthy but because the
movie decided to waste our time with a
bunch of over-the-top nonsense it gets a
sin for not being clever or oxc did you
get a girl drugged out junkie suddenly
gains just enough consciousness to give
Duncan information he needs for the plot
information that would be secondary to
the real task at hand which wants to
kill Duncan and kidnapping his cute
little neighbor that it's personal
where did Camille come into this the
only recon the a-team did was to
determine Duncan actually lived there
there's no way they knew the two of them
were connected except by weak
geographical reasons was trying to kill
him not enough for the story to have
Duncan seek revenge we got to put poor V
hug through some more careful if he
keeps this up there's no way mr. Holland
is gonna get that warm reception to his
opus that he's always wanted who hurt me
mr. Bissell and that cannot be repaid
with a swift impersonal death because
how else are you gonna get out of this
if we don't drag it out and give you
ample opportunity to escape torture
torture torture stabbing guy who
tortures people has favorite records to
play while torturing cliche I mean he
constantly had his hair covering that
out so this really isn't that huge video
right also this last five minutes has
been essentially a montage of Jack
Bauer's worstest hits from 24 and that's
exactly how much fun it sounds like not
that I'm rooting for the blue squad here
but how the hell does an evil
corporation with substantial resources
use a pick up a lock on the restraints
here this ain't the Dark Ages get a
combination lock
despite a tremendous loss of blood no
food getting drugged and being tortured
for three straight days
Duncan moves like misty Copeland and
Swan Lake when he takes out these guards
damn dude you could have just pulled the
lever down and shut off the power it's
at this point that you realize Duncan's
a superhero and even though he's injured
he'll totally kill everyone in this
joint and it's kind of entertaining I'm
not gonna lie but there are no king
stakes to this character once he
survives all day is there any reason why
the movie switches to security cam
footage here does the fact that it's
caught on the security camera become a
factor later certainly doesn't make the
movie any more stylish or easier to
watch has a cleaner shot on Duncan but
besides he's gonna go hand to hand with
him I'm not even mad that's amazing
security cameras don't lie
this fight has taken exactly one month
to complete he wants to trade trade his
life for the girls even in stupid action
film logic how is this even a debate
they don't even have a clue who Camille
is take the goddamn offer immediately
before yes time to recover the safe
rocket science how many men do you have
left no oh come on Duncan took out like
30 guys earlier how many could you
possibly have left it sounds like you
could have fired your entire henchman
Network and gotten the 29 million in
your company needs for its valuation
instead of doing this kill your
assassins at 50 scheme how can I help
you what do you need
I know Duncan has friends all over the
place but the fact that he's got a buddy
in DC that has mad medical skills and
this amount of super advanced weaponry
is seriously testing my suspension of
disbelief did we trace that we're
working on it we have his general
vicinity but we need another call his
last call lasted literally eight seconds
and you couldn't get anything from it
the one before this lasted 15 seconds
and you couldn't even get a general
vicinity hard to believe the cops don't
pull him over for an obvious driving in
a line of evil black SUVs cliche I like
the eyepatch fancy nobody thinks that
Duncan set this whole thing up for a
mass killing the guy who changes the SIM
card out of his phone after every call
who just destroyed the whole army of
henchmen is just going to allow himself
to be found without setting some sort of
trap what makes this worse is that
Vivian knows how dangerous he is and has
been warning Blut the whole movie about
it but goes stupid with the plot means
her to do so yes we do get rusty when
it's on 50 yeah I'm sad I guess we're
just going to neglect that he wiped out
bluets entire team a minute ago good god
man did that scene even happen I'm still
gonna give you a chance to walk out of
life full-time sake the fact that this
is an accurate statement and that these
assholes have an open fire on Duncan
officially takes this down from a fun
b-movie to an f-plus also did this buddy
that nursed him to health also go on a
run took Burberry and get this outfit
she certainly wouldn't have had a
wardrobe in his size right Duncan takes
so long to set up this laser-guided
glove thing that you know what let's
just add 20 centons for the stupidity of
this scene oh cool
didn't endo power glow this is a sequel
to the wizard doesn't really deserve a
sin removal but it's more fun than it
should be and I just can't help myself
in moments like this all right
let me pick you up walk you down the
street and I guess I'll put you in my
car and drive you 2,000 19 miles to
Montana without anyone getting
suspicious about the drugged up chick in
the back seat we'll see how many
Volkswagen bugs we encounter but
remember you gotta yell punch buggy when
you see it or it doesn't count here
comes the revenge portion of the film
where you find out Camille was the girl
in the backseat of the car when Duncan
killed her parents I guess everything
went according to plan just get caught
up in the hit man's life enough to get
kidnapped and drugged survive it have
the hit man take you back home and when
nurses you to health BAM you decorate
the bed with newspaper clippings and
kids world up I can feel my mother's
warm hand wrapped around mine this is an
unexpectedly powerful into the store but
it really feels like the screenwriter
got paid by the adjective in vanessa
hudgens last monologue all the money as
they say wasn't as hard as I thought
damn Camille should have been on the
damocles 18 cuz their asses took forever
to figure it out you know this movie
isn't great or anything am I wrong to
want a sequel to this where Camille is
cap and all sorts of asses with Duncan's
training I am Rob I still want it which
means that I'm sinning myself but this
movie gets to take the brunt of it
and I will live in my turn
I will marry around American woman and I
will have a recreational vehicle I
freaked out join the army professional
killer
[Music]
it's good to see you Duncan
it's good to see you or GERD you're
gonna have to paint everything else I
don't have to do until his birthday
played that's me and his mani I think
he's dead like let's cash in ma we'll be
rich shut the fuck up